Our first lesson is not on one
algorithm in particular, but
on a design technique called,
dynamic programming.
This belongs in the same mental
category as divide and conquer.
It's not an algorithm in itself,
because it doesn't provide
fixed steps to follow.
Rather, it's a general strategy for
thinking about problems, that often
produces an efficient algorithm.
The term dynamic programming,
by the way, is not very descriptive.
The word programming is used
in an older sense of the word,
that refers to any tabular method.
And the word dynamic, apparently,
was just used to make
the technique sound exciting.
With those apologies for the name,
let's dive into the content.